[Music]
I
was in Bihar East India last week I was
talking to some of the women farmers
Erie has been working with and they told
me there were two things that transform
their life significantly in the in the
recent years first was their recognition
as farmers in their own right record
getting that identity
that might seem trivial to a lot of us I
think we take it for granted but these
women have been toiling on their rice
fields for years and generations and
have never been recognized as farmers
they were just unpaid family labor and
as a result they had no access to inputs
no access to technologies no access to
credit Norland and they remained in that
purchase cycle of low productivity and
poverty and incomes and
when they started working with Erie
engaging in the participatory
technology development and evaluation
programs they got access to
technologies like let's say machine
transplanting of rice direct trading of
rice using good agronomic practices you
know managing good nurseries for healthy
seedlings and so on and so on and as a
result they gained a lot of confidence
and started using these practices and
now they're recognized as knowledgeable
and progressive farmers in their own
right by their households by their
communities they saved a lot of time and
energy and they're able to use that time
now to take care of their children's
education look after the household
better would also take care of
themselves and their
being and they said that has made a
significant difference in their lives
improved productivity gave them more
income and
some women saw the economic opportunity
as they started using those Transplant
airs so in their collective in their
self-help group they came together and
then started they bought a machine
transplanter and started a custom hiring
center so when they are providing
machine transplanting services to other
farmers within their village but also
outside and earning some income at the
same time they are also filling a gap
that exists in service provision and as
a result these women are now also being
recognized as budding business woman and
they've gained a lot of credibility and
respect in their communities I mean I
was talking to some of the men in those
villages and they were so proud of their
wives their daughters and
daughters-in-law who were doing this to
put it in context Bihar is a very
patriarchal society has been just for
these women to break those social norms
and take on roles that were
traditionally done by men I mean driving
a machine in the rice field not heard of
before wasn't easy they faced a lot of
sneers and jeers when they started well
they were met people who asked who do
you think you are men what are you even
trying to do but then they persevere
they persisted and and they managed to
do that mainly because they stayed and
worked as a collective being in that
group give them that power as a result
some a lot of these women now have
access to inputs have access to
technologies you know they can rent land
a lot of them have bank accounts
they can get loans and
they are able to make decisions on what
to produce what to sell way to sell and
how to use the income they earned and
that is an example of how
targeting technology is right and using
the right process to get them to Berman
can make a significant difference in
power relations within the households
within the communities and within the
society
[Music]